SPEAKER: Do you know what
happens when you say, OK Google?
TinyML or Tiny Machine Learning
is one of the fastest growing
fields of machine learning.
It sits right at the
intersection of embedded systems,
algorithms, and computing hardware.
TinyML is all about on-device machine
leanring right at the endpoint
where the data resides,
and it is fundamentally
different than running machine learning
in big data centers or in the cloud.
You already know and take for granted
some existing applications with TinyML.
For instance, when you say, hey
Siri, OK Google, or hey Alexa,
you're seeing TinyML in action.
But those applications are
just the tip of the iceberg.
TinyML has many different use cases
ranging from smart home appliances
to medical devices,
and it has applications
even in wildlife conservation.
This exciting new professional
certificate program
is a Harvard collaboration
with innovative members
of Google's TensorFlow team.
This certificate combines
computer science with engineering,
and it features real-world
application case studies
that examine TinyML deployments.
This program takes you
through the foundations
of TinyML to deploying machine
learning on your very own device.
In the Foundations of
TinyML course, you'll
learn the basics of embedded
computing and discover the language
behind Tiny Machine Learning.
In course 2, which focuses
on applications of TinyML,
you'll get the opportunity
to see TinyML in practice
and learn the code behind some of
the most common applications today.
Finally in Deploying TinyML, you'll
write the machine learning code
using Google's latest TensorFlow
Lite for microcontrollers
and program your very own smart device.
We're just beginning to explore
the full capabilities of TinyML.
Imagine what we could do if there were
smart, ideally biodegradable machine
learning sensors everywhere.
Be at the forefront of
this emerging technology,
and start learning TinyML today.